C'est adorable, ça.
Il faut aller voter pour lui,
il faut aller voter pour lui.
Il est là pour,
pour les faibles,
les gens qui sont sans voix.
Il représente la voix des sans voix
et il va vous représenter.
Voilà, donc, sortez massivement ce jour-là,
allez voter pour lui.
Voilà, je vous demande pardon.
Ne dormez pas,
ne dites pas que la politique ne nous intéresse pas.
La politique intéresse tout le monde.
Quand tu ne t'intéresses pas à la politique,
elle s'intéresse à toi.
Et c'est-ce qu'on vit ?
Vous voyez, dans les magasins, tout est cher,
on peut rien faire, on peut rien manger.
Votez des gens, bon, pour pouvoir vous défendre,
c'est très important.
Bisous et puis à bientôt,
ça va ? Oh merci Rachel.
Oh non mais vraiment.